>>Natalie Walchuk: Art is so
powerful in a school community.
It's a place where children can find
expression for their deepest emotions
or just the fun and silly ones, and
it's a quick, easy space for kids
to find a way to talk and
communicate with each other.
>>At Glenview we partnered
with local community artists
to support social-emotional learning,
communication, conflict resolution
and to help students build
partnerships across boundaries.
When we looked at our data we found
that we had challenges
with girl relationships.
A lot of our time was
being spent resolving them,
so we reached out to Allison
Kenny who brought us Girl Power
to help solve all of our
girl-friendship issues.
>>Allison Kenny: This
game is called "Yes!"
What's it called?
>>Students: Yes!
>>Allison Kenny: Because in Go
Girls we practice saying "Yes!"
to the things that are fun
and the things that we can do
to feel good about ourselves.
>>Natalie Walchuk: We found great
success with our Girl Power program
so we expanded to Kid Power.
We brought it into the
classroom for every student,
girls and boys, during
the school day.
>>Allison Kenny: This is what
our kid power can help us do.
Okay. Show me your trashcan.
>>Natalie Walchuk: The Kid Power
trashcan is a tangible way for kids
to manage hurtful words and throw
them away to keep their hearts safe.
>>Allison Kenny: I love it.
Okay, I'm just pretending.
Here we go.
You're stupid.
Catch it, throw it away, hand
on your heart, say, "I am-- "
>>Student: I am so nice.
>>Allison Kenny: Give
him a round of applause.
>>Natalie Walchuk:
Communication skills are taught
through our Art Without
Judgment class.
It's taught byJahi ,
our resident artist,
and it helps students
learn how to give feedback
in respectful ways to their peers.
>>Jahi: Today we're gonna
work on our language.
And the language we want to work
on are "Wows" and "Wonders".
>>Natalie Walchuk: Jahi's
students are thinking critically
when they reflect on
each other's work.
They offer an affirmation first
and then a critical question
to keep everyone digging deeper.
>>Student: I wonder why
Cameron crossed his out?
>>Jahi: You know, I wonder that, too.
To make it a snowflake.
Michaela, here's my wow for you.
Wow I like the frame of it
and I wonder who's that?
>>Student: I think
you did a good job.
>>Student: I think you did, too.